new at 11 o'clock is it a clunker or a
classic car the definition of a vintage
vehicle is at the heart of new changes
that are coming to state law and at a
town hall meeting tonight many car
owners are frustrated about closing a
registration loophole which would
improve nevada's air quality sasha
loftis was at tonight's meeting and
joins us live in studio with more on
those changes denise tonight's
discussion got pretty heated as many
people say these new regulations
aren't realistic but the dmv and local
officials say it's important to improve
our overall air quality
it makes no sense
you're going after one and a half
percent of the people a passionate
discussion over a change for classic
cars if my smartphone fails
what am i supposed to do if it doesn't
pass small wednesday's town hall focused
on nevada assembly bill 349 that will
close a years-long loophole for vehicles
with classic tags there are a lot of
cars that are currently registered as
classic cars
but these vehicles are not actually
classic cars starting january 1st this
registration will require a smog check
designated classic or antique insurance
and a cap of 5 000 miles per year a lot
of those vehicles that are on the road
which are also polluting the air clark
county commissioner william mccurdy ii
says the goal is to improve air quality
obviously that's going to hinder a lot
of people's ability to get to and from
work but people like d'anthony brim say
this will impact those who can't afford
to fix their cars those are most people
who don't understand
how the system affects them until it's
directly affecting them and they're
asking those at the state and local
level to understand their frustrations
as this all moves forward what is your
definition of classic 1965 mustang
there's a lot more than that
the department of environmental and
sustainability also discussed a vehicle
repair program pilot that would help
those who qualify with emission related
repairs next year brian